billah
[Silence]
continuing
in our journey
through actually a summary
of U originally in its original form in
which
Shin authored it is about five volumes
roughly five volumes and it's going
to be
over over roughly about ,000 Pages we
obviously are going through the gist of
it the important aspects of it what is
intended for
everybody and this great book we
have reached to the part
of now we're going to start to discuss
how the prophet sallallah Al wasam would
pray at night his night time
prayer this is what is referred to
as the praying at night right this
standing at night to pray also referred
to
asud right
and the prayer of the night and all of
these are names for a similar thing and
that is those additional prayers that
are prayed
from the time of to the time of f all
right anytime between there this is
referred to
as and contrary to popular belief a
person does not have to sleep or have
slept as a
prerequisite to
pray so some people are under the
impression that in order for me to pray
at night and for it to be counted as
night
prayer or or what have you it has to
occur after I have slept some people
say even a moment even a moment's sleep
is enough to have that and that is
not
correct what's important about this tud
is the timing of
tud not necessarily what you have done
or failed to do between those and so the
timing is anywhere
from all the way
until that is the time
of how much is a person to pray in
well as a general rule that we took last
week the prophet
s
said that prayer at night is to be
performed in units of two meth it's to
be performed in units of
two this is if we take it as this
companion understood it now imagine
yourself asking the prophet S.I wasam
you don't know what he prays at night
you don't know how he prays at night
this is why you're asking you go to him
and you say oh my messenger of Allah how
do I pray at night what is praying at
night how much should I pray at night he
says and he says to you prayer at night
should be performed in units of
Two And if you Fe if you feel that the
dawn is approaching them pray one ra and
it will make odd everything that you
prayed before this is what he tells you
what do you understand from this you
understand from this that pray as much
as you anywhere from two to a
thousand however many units of two you
can fit into those hours is what is
permissible and this is the correct
understanding this is a correct way to
understand it that if an
individual prays at night he is to pray
units of two and he is to pray or she is
to pray as much as they anywhere
from two all the way to hundreds if
you if you so desire that is that is
fine
now what did the prophet s. wasam used
to pray well this is what is going to
tell us about it's important for us to
understand this concept
because which we pray as a which is
actually just it's according to our
definition of what is is that's correct
that's exactly what it is it's just
referred to as for a number of reasons
but one of the reasons is to distinguish
that this is something that is done
collectively in the Masid most usually
with the Imam of the Masjid as a
congregation only in the month of
Ramadan that this is done
consistently and
so the same rules of apply
to if you understand that you understand
that the same rules
of are the same rules
of now how much should we pray
in well we have what the prophet
sallallah alai wasallam used to pray
and that is the narration of which we'll
get to here
inshallah that the prophet Sall was
would pray in Ramadan and outside of
Ramadan
11 right and then another narration 13
which we'll discuss that
discrepancy
right this is what the prophet
sallallahu alai wasallam
prayed and we have no reason to believe
that for those two or three nights that
the prophet sallallah alaihi wasallam
did
lead that he prayed any more than that
that's exactly how many he prayed with
the
companions but now if a person wishes to
pray what the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam prayed then that is
definitively what he
prayed now where does the issue of 20 or
eight come into
play with regards to the
different this is a a big issue of
debate in many mosques should a person
pray eight or pray 20 right the answer
is all of that is
fine the best thing to do is to pray
what the prophet s wasallam prayed which
is what we spoke
about but it's all Al permissible to
pray more right it's also permissible to
pray more and it's been narrated that
Omar and others of the companions prayed
20 this is where this number comes from
this is where the imams of the various M
got this number from also in Other M
it's mentioned 40 and and other numbers
and so it's not a set fixed number the
best number the easiest number for
everyone the number that we can all
agree on
is what the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam did but this doesn't mean that
it is an innovation or it is Haram or it
is not the Sunnah and all these other
slurs that are being thrown out there by
people who do not understand this issue
do not understand the root of this issue
and so if there is a Masid or an IM that
prays 20 ra we pray 20 if it's 30 we
pray 30 with the Imam if it's eight we
pray eight with the Imam if it's 50 we
pray 50 and there's no innovation being
introduced here with this
number right and so is this the best
thing to do well that's a difference of
it's an issue that depends on the
community and depends on the Imam
depends on what the people are
comfortable with what they're used to
but it doesn't mean that it is Haram
or an innovation or or any of these
words that people throw out there and
believe it to be a simple Affair to
brand something as such without
Authority from Allah to do
so so this is a very important issue
it's an issue
of we understand what the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam did and then
we understand what the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam allowed or
would have
allowed right this is what true f is
and understanding is what he allowed or
what he would have
allowed okay hypothetically based on the
generalities of his statements Etc and
so it's important for us to understand
this issue we will get to a portion here
where will discuss fasting he will
discuss prayer Etc he will discuss
and fasting and and Ramadan and so forth
but it's important for us to to learn
this the prophet
Sall gave a general
encouragement to pray with the IM
whatever the IM prays
during and so he said s. wasallam that
which means whoever prays with the IM
whoever prays with the
IM until the IM is finished and
concludes and leaves then this person
will receive the reward of someone who
prayed all night so this is a general
encouragement that you pray with the
Imam until he finishes in Ramadan in and
this is why we always encourage people
to
pray the wi with the IM we notice
that a lot of people in Ramadan they'll
stand to pray with the
IM and they'll pray with him until he
reaches e ra right or 10 and then
they'll leave because they're going to
go pray at home by themselves and then
pray with it after that this is not what
is best this is actually the opposite of
what is best what is best is to stay
with the Imam until he completes and if
you wish to pray after that in your home
alone then that is fine as long as you
do it in units of two also another thing
that we need to be careful of and that
is the issue of
r that when I leave at8 ra it's almost
an indicator that I'm going to pray
at home alone so I have to be aware of
this that I don't wear this as a badge
or that I don't do this in order that
people think that oh mashallah he's
going to pray at home he's he's a heavy
hitter at home by himself this is also
very dangerous and something that we
need to take into consideration and
so when we
pray the best thing to do is to pray
with the Imam until he finishes makes
wit we make wit along with the Imam and
then if a person wishes to pray after
that then they pray in units of two as
the
prophet said he
[Silence]
says he says the prophet Al wasam would
never leave off praying the night prayer
this is regardless of whether he was
traveling or a resident and if he is was
overwhelmed by exhaustion or was
you know if he was tired particularly
tired or if he was sick or ill or in
pain from something or some injury then
he would pray during the
day 12
and when we say during the day we're
speaking about
between and which
is he would pray
12 so if he missed it at night he would
pray it in the day now 12 ra but he
would pray at night
11 right notice this here he would pray
in the narration OFA she tells us that
he would pray 11
ra right that he would constantly pray
11 meaning that he would pray all of the
the you know what what is eight two two
two two then he would pray a and then he
would pray one that would make
11 and other narrations 13 that 13 is
incorporating the two of
the
two because he would pray just
until would make the after which would
seem he's making two right after F
or that's incorporating the two
of right this or that so it's 11 at
night this is the correct
understanding of that inshallah so he
would pray 11 ra
but if he would miss it purposely miss
it notice the wording
of thata
says that if he would be particularly
tired mean he would fall asleep and he
wouldn't wake up or he was in some kind
of he was Ill or some kind of
circumstance that would make it
difficult for him to pray at night he
would get a full night's rest and he
would pray the next day between F and he
would pray 12 ra 12 not 11 why
12 well tells us why he says
[Silence]
he says the reason that it was 12 and
not 11 when he would make it up
between and he says I heard
Islam now this is speaking about his his
main and the main conduit of Islam's
works are
is and also he was referred to as Islam
in his time before his
death and it's anomalous it's
anomalous and often
throughout Z
throughout all the works of actually
I can't really think of any book
of in which he doesn't mention ISL
except perhaps
for his book AR which is about the soul
that he spoke about and it's a
difference of opinion whether this is
actually his book or not but most of his
books are going to be mentioning
Islam in some way or shape or form right
are quoting him as
well
mentions and he quotes him or he
mentions his word without quoting him
for political reasons and so this is
found and it's anomalous that a person
would try
to distinguish
between and IB Tam it's
it is a contradiction and thought
because anyone who is well aware of ib's
works and well aware of's Works know
that they're the same thing and you
can't take one without the other right A
lot of times people will to take
the students of IB and
reject and a lot of people speak bad of
him without knowledge of doing so so we
and we and we and we like
and we
and we all of these different
Andi and all these other Scholars and
we take their works and we rever them
and we hold them in high esteem and
rightfully so but then we scoff
at even though he is either their direct
she or the she of their she and so this
is something which is which is very
anomalous the reason that people do this
is
because had a lot of enemies because of
the time that he came
in because of the political landscape at
the time and also because of his
because of
his
General character he was a person
that was described
by that he was described by shabi in a
in a portion where he documents The
Life and Times of a lost portion
from he mentions that IB
Tam
was very
Fierce and he would come off as kind of
harsh and even kind of
pompous or arrogant this is how he
would come off not that he was that
but in debate right this is how he would
come off
so he described and he said he said that
he May honor you and belittle you in
the same Gathering right meaning that
he's a very nice person he's a very good
person but when debate starts or when
issues are discussed he becomes very
focused and because he would see
things so clearly in his mind other
people would perceive this to be
something arrogant that he's arrogant or
that he's boastful or that he is
that this is pacity which is which it
was not obviously I
mean if you read truly his life and
times you would see that he is
very very humble individual right
very humble individual however the
way that people may perceive him
especially when he would disagree with
them or they would disagree with him is
and that he would come off in this way
and
so he mentions something very important
about
in he says he says
if had a bit of
siasa and Gent ESS about him with his
enemies with his antagonists if he was a
little bit more gentle and he was a
little bit more political in the way
that he dealt with
them he says if he had just added that
characteristic he would have been
somebody who everybody agreed upon and
had gotten behind and endorsed his his
opinions but because of that that
kind of element or that air of harshness
and that air of what people perceived
to be that he was unapproachable or that
he was somebody who was arrogant and
this wasn't the case but this is how his
enemies perceived him especially those
whom who felt injured by him or
personally attacked by him this is
why he accumulated so many enemies and
this is why or one of the main reasons
that he had so many enemies there
were so many rumors there were he was
put in prison and so forth right this is
the reason according to
shamid this is correct and this is why
most people
are most or a lot of
people we find are more willing to
accept
right
even and accept their works even though
they are saying the exact same thing
that
said many of them actually went to
prison with him was imprisoned
with was imprisoned
with and some of them would deliberately
try to find the M themselves
imprisoned in order to spend time
with in his two stints in prison
the last of which he died and so it's
important to understand this when we
discuss IB a lot of people have been
given these ideas about IB T that he is
aim and that he is a V and that he is
all of these things and that he
literally
describes Allah and Likens Allah to
his creation all of these things these
things are out outright lies and
this is a
collective of problems number one people
read The Works of I Tamia and they do
not understand what he's saying the
works of IB Tamia honestly are very
complicated he de deals with issues that
are extremely complex and he deals them
with them in a way that is almost
scattered when you read him and Tam me
his Works he comes off almost as
scattered because he will speak about
one issue but Branch off into many
different issues sometimes for dozens or
even hundreds of pages before he goes
back and addresses the original issue
and this is just because he would write
how he would think
so his works are very hard to
understand and so
if a person is not patient and is not
ready and is not able to understand isia
when they read They're going to be very
they are going to be very
unclear as to what it is he's
actually saying another reason is
because of these political things he
had a lot of antagonists and enemies at
the time of Scholars who were very very
prominent and still are you know you
know Taj subki and saf and all
these other Scholars who have
done a lot for Islam at the time
even though they felt personally
attacked by Tamia and in turn they
attacked him and they attacked him in
the harshest of ways and so it's
important for us not
to jump on someone else's
bandwagon this is an important
point it's important for us never to
jump on someone else's
bandwagon it is a fool who makes others
other people's enemies his own for
reasons that he doesn't understand right
so you never want to just say oh well my
said that Tami is terrible and then you
go out to the world and speak about this
right this is something that is very
dangerous you don't want to do this and
on the day of
Resurrection you know you or when
you're put in your grave you're not
going to be asked
about going to be asked about
yourself and if Allah subhanahu waala
says about and if excuse me the prophet
Sall was says with regards to the people
of the book right the priests and rabbis
who do at the time clearly had
physically and and physically and
meaningfully changed the books of
Allah subhanahu waala to control people
to control the masses this is what they
did Allah tells us
that right that they would change the
meanings and change the actual wording
at
times but yet in spite of this the
prophet s. was tells
us if the people of the book tell you of
something do not deny it and do not
accept it right how much more so a
scholar of Islam such as Islam Tamia
whose Works have filled the world and
his students have completely changed
the topography and the landscape of
scholarship and there was a great
Revival in the time of Sheik
and so if you wish to separate
between and you're going to have a
problem
because
and for example the great they were the
ones who bathed after he passed away if
you wish to separate between
and you're going to have an anomaly on
your hands a problem why because
spent most of his time and dedicated the
remainder of his life from when he met
until he died expounding upon the works
of I Tami and documenting them right and
so on and so forth and so it's important
that we don't ever take on other
people's battles and jump on some
bandwagon not knowing what it is we're
doing or saying right our words do have
effects and
so for a person not to say something
is much more constructive if they don't
have anything positive to say and
so and also as another note there were
some Scholars that came about in the
10th Century 11th century 12th century
that have written books about even even
and referred to them with very terrible
names referring to them as as idiots and
fools and donkeys and stupid and all of
these words that are not used by the
scholars of Islam the scholars of Islam
even when they differ even when they
refute one another they don't speak like
this they don't talk this Scholars
of Islam have respect and they follow
the general gu guidelines of the
Quran and tell my servants to say that
which is best
right whoever believes in Allah in the
last days he's to speak with that which
is good or remain silent right so this
is an issue that we have to keep in mind
and
so whenever you hear these kinds of
slurs or words or accusations or things
that are really based on suspicion right
this is when we have to stop and say it
looks you know I'm seeing evidence
of a Shan's handiwork in this speech and
so I don't want to have anything any
part of it right and leave scholarship
for Scholars is very
important say
he says the fact that the prophet s.
wasam would
pray as 11 but if he missed it now again
back to the wording purposely missed it
because he's tired or whatever then he
would pray at the next day between F and
and in the time of D he would pray it as
12 rather than 11 Islam comments and
says in this is an Evidence and an
indication that that one wi that one
of wi is something that if you purposely
miss it you cannot make it up why
because it's time has passed its
appropriate time has
passed he says this is very this is
similar
to praying two when you enter into the
Masid if a person purposely doesn't do
this and a purpose a person knowingly
doesn't do this and you know then
then leaves or or comes back later or
whatever it is and and decides you know
I won't do it now I'll do it in an hour
the person cannot make this up why
because its proper place has been has
been it's it's been taken out of its
proper place likewise the eclipse prayer
if a person sees the
eclipse and decides not to pray the
eclipse prayer I'm busy now I'll pray it
later the eclipse is over and then he
goes and prays it he can't make up the
eclipse
prayer because it is supposed to be for
the eclipse if that occasion has passed
then he cannot make it up
likewise which is when we pray a
particular prayer to ask for rain right
if a person says well I'll ask later
I'll do later and then rain comes in the
meanwhile they can't make this up
because its time has passed he
says and the reason is that the point of
wi it's spirit is that it be the kind of
cap or the crown that you you Crown the
entirety of your prayer at night with
and so if you pray it in the daytime
it's self-defeating
he
says and the prophet sallam would pray
at night 11 Al together as we
mentioned he says or
13 this is what we discussed earlier
the discrepancy found in the narration
of
he says all of the scholars and
companions agree to the lower number
which is 11 right and then some mention
that extra
number he says and that extra two ra
that would have make it 13
this has been differed upon are these
two ra part of the prayer at night or
are they part of the fud Sunnah or
what are they exactly this is something
which has been a difference of opinion
amongst the scholars and understanding
and we just discussed that and we
clarified
it he says
[Silence]
now gives us a general ruling a general
principle he
says if we look at all of what the
prophet S.I wasam would pray in the day
and in the night
starting from the five daily prayers
with their respective Sunan and the
nighttime prayers
Etc if we add all of those together
which he would always without fail
pray we find that he would pray in every
day and night 40 ra this was his word
this is how much he would normally pray
he would always pray these for
and anything extra that is mentioned
then that is something which is not
consistent it's not something he
consistently did it's something that he
occasionally did right such as before or
two before or four as opposed to two
before right or two or or Etc
right all of these are considered to be
extra or for example two or four
before that he would make sometimes
occasionally there are some others
that are mentioned such as six after
sration is
in right an encouragement to pray six
after 222 this is a week narration
inauthentic the only thing
authentic with regards to pray after
is
right he
[Silence]
says then he says something very
beautiful he says and so it's
important and it is befitting of
every servant to constantly try to
pray this word that we have
concretely from the prophet sallallah
alaih wasallam of 40 collectively in the
way that we just mentioned that a person
should pray this and they should pray it
until their death right he says and the
reason for this is that how Swift and
how quick
the answered prayers come about when
a person does such a thing and how
often and reliably the the door is
opened for a person who the
proverbial door of Allah subana waala is
answering for a person who knocks on
that door 40 times every day and night
and
Allah another side issue that we'd
to mention before we end and that
is
understanding Islamic scholarship in
Islam there is a lot of propaganda and
misinformation about Islamic
scholarship okay this is an important
issue it is of the utmost important
because what I see is that we have been
instilled and this comes from a very
long history
that the Muslim has okay
especially in the last 200 years we need
to understand this issue very well
before we can
continue There is an issue and there is
an understanding that later Muslim
centuries meaning especially the last
200 years when the
Muslim Empire if you will and the
Muslim
fell apart and began to become
unraveled this happened mainly because
the Muslims started to slowly lean
into the life of this world and prefer
it over the Hereafter on an individual
level this was a collective thing it's
not just because we had bad leaders and
it's not just because we had bad
followers it was a it was a it was a
collection of both elements that led to
this and
so when we see this we see that a lot of
this came from influences foreign
influences upon the Muslim Empire
that the Muslims began to adopt
technology from foreign non-muslim
Nations and the these foreign non-muslim
nations were very often Nations
that were constantly at the gates
of the Muslim empire trying to
infiltrate it and wish to see the demise
of the Muslim
empire and so when they would when
they would procure these Technologies
into the Muslim world when we say
technology we're speaking about
everything from Factory to military
to the way people dress and and customs
and so forth they would likewise
import the culture and certain ideas
along with this technology right certain
ideas because a technology is is built
any invention it comes with a certain
mindset along with it and that mindset
could be in accordance with Islam and it
could be not in accordance with Islam
and so when this technology was imported
a lot of the
non-muslim and not just non-muslim
but
you know foreign influences that did
not have the Muslim
Empire best in best wishes at
heart right what happened is the
Muslim mindset began to
change and so when we look at the
Muslims around us especially Muslims
that have come from other countries
especially but not
only we are seeing not Muslims as they
originally are in the time of the
greatness of Islam this is not what
we're seeing we are seeing people that
come
from war torn
ravaged colonized
countries that have managed to cling on
to what is left of what they know about
Islam so when you meet a Palestinian
you're meeting somebody who has come
from hundreds of years of occupation by
different countries and different
influences when you meet somebody from
Saudi Arabia or the Arab peninsula
you're meeting someone who has only
recent ly come out of the desert
someone who is very new to technology
and thought and their thought is rather
behind because of the fact that they
were either colonized or they were in
a state of extreme ignorance far from
cities and far from civilization etc etc
when you meet someone from North
Africa for instance Morocco or Algeria
or Tunis or Libya you're meeting people
that have been occupied for sometimes
hundreds of years by the French or the
Italians or and these occupational
forces did not just occupy that land
they occupied those people's minds right
and so they would pass laws such as
prohibition to speak the Arabic language
sometimes in communist occupied lands
and other places they would prohibit
people from reading the Quran or praying
they would prohibit people from fasting
and we're seeing that even today even in
China people are being prohibited from
fasting and
force-fed pork and forced women
forced to live in houses with foreign
men who are not Muslim and they
call this you know education and
re-education and all these fancy names
which is not new to communist propaganda
and and so the point here is that we're
not seeing in the Muslims a reflection
of true Islam as it was we are seeing
the remnants and the
residual pieces of Islam mixed with a
lot of foreign influence this is
important because there are number of
ideas which we have been infected with
that we have confused with with Islamic
principles
this happens when scholarship becomes
weak right and
so one of these principles is a general
suspicion towards all Scholars and this
is very dangerous as a matter of fact
it's become almost a meme almost a
laughing issue that you know imams and
Scholars they usually are really fat and
they're usually just laying around
taking people's money and eating and
tricking people and they're usually very
very unworthy people and yes we do
see some of that but that is not the
origin of Islamic scholarship and often
times we
compare Muslim Scholars to Scholars
of previous Nations Scholars of
previous Nations people of the book we
say well look at what those people did
yes the scholars of the people of the
book of previous Nations the
scholars of the people of m
al the people of Isa and all the way
back we are it is taught to us that
these people were a very a majority
of of an evil people who exchanged the
life of this world for the Hereafter and
played with the revelations of Allah
waala but that is not the case for
scholarship of Islam the Islamic
scholarship is not that way and this is
one of the things that is particular to
the prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam and that is that he said s
he said that prophets do not leave
behind an inheritance of gold or silver
they rather leave behind an inheritance
of knowledge and so whoever takes or is
given a portion of this knowledge this
person has taken a very huge portion of
inheritance and a great Fortune
meaning from Allah subhanahu waala and
he said sallallah wasam
he said
sallam that the people of the children
of Israel they were a people whom
prophets were a constant fixture in
their Community every time a prophet
would pass away a a new Prophet would be
appointed by Allah and ra raised up
to take his place and carry on that
mantle he says sallallah alai wasam
indeed there is no Prophet after me
what there will be is there will be
Scholars and this is one of the aspects
that the scholars of Islam mention is
one of the particulars of the nation of
Muhammad s. wasam that sets this nation
aside from the rest
of the rest of the nations of the
prophets and Messengers and that is that
the the the scholars of
Islam they actually take the place of
prophethood in previous Nations this is
a great honor for Scholars this is also
something that we have to understand and
that is the essence of a scholar is that
he or she is someone of Integrity
someone of honesty someone of knowledge
if he is a
scholar now what happens
is we start to we start to confuse real
scholarship with people that masquerade
as Scholars that's a different issue
altogether most of the people that
you meet that you probably think are
Scholars are not okay scholarship has
been defined by some Scholars as knowing
more about Islam than you don't
which is a lot of knowledge right
knowing more of the Sunnah than you
don't knowing more of the rulings of
Allah than you don't knowing more of
History than you don't that's a lot of
information and that is we're speaking
about decades and Decades of research
and and learning in order to reach
such a high level if a person really
is a
scholar and who tells us who is a
scholar other Scholars tell us we don't
tell them we don't know who is a scholar
from who isn't most people confuse
Scholars for people who wear fancy
clothes and put the pens in their pocket
and have the glasses on and the fancy
robes and the fancy clothes and when
they read the Quran they've got this
very harmonous beautiful voice and that
that is the epitome of scholarship that
is not the epitome of scholarship ship
real Scholars or people who have
spent most of their lives engrossed
in learning the essence of Islam and
learning the spirit of Islam and
carrying on the mantle of the Prophet
sallallah wasam these people we
essentially think of them as good there
may be some bad apples but that is the
exception not the norm one of the things
that the foreign influence
did in order to turn the Muslims in on
themselves and to be able to weaken the
Muslim resolve is to turn them against
their own Scholars and we're speaking
about true scholarship and in the last
200 years a lot of things have been
affected including Islamic scholarship
and yes there are countries that appoint
Scholars right and they appoint these
Scholars not based on their knowledge
but they appoint them based on political
reasons and political agenda and those
people obviously their scholarship
and their trustworthiness is is brought
into question by a lot of things that
they do but the point that I'm making
here is we should not have this idea
that whenever a scholar speaks if he
truly is a scholar if he is someone who
is respectable and known to be a person
who is not a scholar
of political scholar but a a real
scholar of Islam the
is that this person is trustworthy and
this person is truthful and this
person is pious and this person is not
the other way around this is
something that's important for us to
understand we'll continue next week
in